pop
[Musique]
les oncles et non quand tu vois une
cartouche de jeu
je vous en prie les bourgs et boum mais
je bouffe m'a fallu au titre qu'est ce
que ça vous fait oh non non non et non
là vous entendez ces traits pour la
première preuve d'amour que je vous
demande
on a beau me remercie vous commencez par
la dernière a aussi vous donner des
numéros d'ordre mais enfin qu'est ce que
je vous demande après tout une chose
qu'une taburet notre champ qui
sympathisent notre mari s'en va à la
chasse
je suis son ami il est normal que je
vous demande de me consacrer votre
soirée des commandos jusqu'à demain
matin et demain matin de bonne heure
parce qu'il faut que soit huit heures
mais a fait retirer les antennes ne
voulait pas confiance en moi
enfin voyons grant 106 en admettant même
que je vois est ce que vous voulez mon
aiguille vous ne pensez donc pas que
j'aie ma réputation a sauvegardé
qu'est ce que les gens direct au
concierge et domestiques s'apercevait
que je ne rentre pas ce soir quelques
heures j'ai chaud mais vous voyez
toujours les choses par leur petit côté
comme si une femme ne pouvait pas
toujours à donner le change un peu ce
marché de l'art grand s'effaceront être
29 mai enfin vous n'êtes pas sans avoir
une parente à la campagne oui ma
marraine est bas alors votre mari sa
récente vous allez chez votre mauvaise
et en chemin je bifurque connaissent pas
mais je m'arrête car entre d'athènes
dans le petit pied-à-terre de monsieur
maurice est oui
donc vous voyez allant dans votre
appartement de garçons très bien pour
m'amuser mais que c'est drôle puisque
c'est tout près vous le savez bien en
voilà une raison
je me demande alors pourquoi quand je
vous ai confié à vous et à vous seuls
car j'ai pris bien soin de ne pas ouvrir
la bouche à votre mari que j'avais
l'intention de prendre une petite carte
infirmières et que j'hésitais entre
plusieurs appartements
vous m'avez dit prenez celui là nous
serons tout près or madame quand vous
m'avez dit ça je n'ai eu de cesse que je
n'ai vu mon bail en poche j'ai passé
surtout l'appartement était occupée par
une brave locataires noël urbaine des
voitures qu'il avait contre elle que
lire régularité avec laquelle elle
payait son terme
j'ai obtenu son expulsion du
propriétaire et est un chevalier
français non seulement vous m'aviez dit
prenons celui là nous serons tout près
alors voilà bien nous sommes de nature
différente
mais quand vous m'avez dit prenez dont
je suis la pelouse seront tous prêts et
ben moi j'avais pensé que j'avais
compris ça
vous avez une jerry opinion nous mais si
vous croyez que je fréquente les
appartements gars moi prendre une chose
pareille offre au mas dieu merci 30
wittrant oui mais je croyais toujours
être l'estiment pour vous si je pense
est une chose pareille mais non je vous
dis venez chez moi parce que c'est chez
moi c'est que ça ne sort pas d'entre
nous mais si je vous croyais capable de
vendre là là on va mais qu'est ce que
vous seriez dont à peu près la même
chose ça vous trouvez vous à coup tu
n'avais vraiment pas le sentiment d'être
lancé alors mettons que je n'ai pas le
sentiment d'innocence puisque je ne
l'est pas et vient en parlant plus
voulez-vous n'ont pas non plus et bien
c'est certain je ne vous en parle
je n'ai qu'un regret c'est de vous en
avoir peur mais on va alors étouffé le
regrette mais continuant de partouche
les fameux tenez voilà les femmes alors
vous y renoncer ah oui j'ai renoncé
s'être pervers c'est vrai les camus et
ben je n'ose encore plus de cartons de
jouer ce rôle ridicule de fabriquer des
cartouches pour monsieur votre mari
comme moi qui vous avait placé si haut à
vous même fait tomber là d'un sixième
étage enfin c'est égal je remercie le
ciel de vous savoir mise à nu devant moi
non je parle au figuré à cet heureux
et bien alors
fava qui comme vous voulez non pas du
tout vraiment ici le château n'est pas
parler pour vous même en nature
bouillante comme la vienne ouah ouah on
fait tous ces efforts pourraient et
quand on en est toujours au même point
mois elio di rupo d'être allé trop vite
en besogne et donc la patience que
diable tu n'es pas un recours ce temps
là ni à la course ni alors monsieur
maria tués aux dépens je t'offrirai bien
devant médéa non ben non je viendrai
plus tôt ben oui je me suis dit il à ma
famille sont un peu vite sans moi nous
voyons un très bon et les bornes mais ce
voyage est stupide de se faire enlever
sans pareil pour si peu de choses
tiens regarde que moi avec mon fusil est
ce que je m'énerve c'est pourtant je
n'arrive pas à le nettoyer ça s'écrit
n'y arrive pas c'est probablement que tu
ne sais pas te prendre tu sais mon toit
maintien mais comment fais-tu quand il
venait je l'envoie chez l'armurier
encore fraîches ont aimé la voir
souffrir des animaux non mais même un
homme moi je ne peux pas et c'est un
médecin qui parle et donc c'est chez son
amie cassandre que tu vas faire mais
quand on suit toujours
on ne veut pas souvent ici ton amie
cassandre à risque j'essayais ne bouge
pas ta campagne c'est un et les chercher
l'oubli de ses malheurs conduite de
rossi malheur il est séparé de sa femme
ça c'est pas trouvé cet établissement
même qu'aux jeunes l'en blâme certains
ce sont là des c4 respectable la digne
femme elle avait un amant
au moins elle pourquoi dis-tu en avant
au moins tu es dans l'acide urique rendu
plusieurs noms ne sais pas dit elle
avait un amant au moins elle s'est dit
elle avait un amant virgules au moins
elle même c'est wade comprend mal que je
ne saisis pas la finesse la réflexion
n'a pas besoin et puis je trouve bon
quoique dit elle avait un artiste
français parce que ma fille en main mais
qu'est ce qu'une enseigne mari
d'ailleurs les maris sont toujours les
derniers à voir clair
ces choses-là des présomptions oui mais
pas assez même ce qui enrage ce brave
k.sign ne pas en avoir parce qu'alors il
pourrait faire convertir sa séparation
en divorce tandis que son noces là il
faut le consentement des deux parties
et comme madame est opposé oui oui mais
et puis ça lui supprimerait sa pension
ah ça c'est une catholique mitigé au
sacré fusil sur ma foi je crois que je
suis votre conseil je vais l'envoyer
chez l'armurier binôme avait alors c'est
bien entendu une fois deux fois trois
fois vous ne voulez pas encore rentré
mon ami vous savez quand vous viendrez
me raconter maintenant vous m'aimez haut
en effet je ne dirais pas que vous
n'avez pas dit enfin souvenez vous de
retrouver russie elle venait de mourir
votre pauvre petit perruches cnt lui
demandait si gentiment vous la défunte
et moi votre mari lui été sorti
vous souvenez vous de votre crise de
larmes un émoi qui vous consoler et vous
pleuriez sur ma poitrine à ses pleurs et
je me serais dans mes bras je ne sais
plus ce que je faisais mes larmes se
mêlent aux vôtres pourrait poser la
perruche sur le pouf
c'est à ce moment là que vous y tient de
ses élans du coeur te demande pas cela
et alors où le laissa échapper ce je
vous aime qui est cause du ch était
comme fou votre mari arriva sur ces
entrefaites jeudi que le temps de me
saisir de ma perruche pour me donner une
contenance et nous continuâmes salah
pleurait tous les trois ensemble arnaud
on dirait patrie ne vais parties se
chevauchent am qui pose de tout ce que
l'on sait ce que vaut 10 dans ces
monodoses était sincère il ya maintenant
c'est court instant où la femme ne pense
plus du tout à ce qu'elle dit qu'on peut
être sûr qu'elle dit vraiment quelconque
mais quand je le redis ce je vous aime
est ce que cela implique tout tout ce
qui s'en suit après je ne sais pas ce
que vous me suis vu ce que tu comme pas
au bout d'un jeu vous
hu à part dieu c'est bien beau de dire
aux gens qu'on les aime encore faut-il
le prouver
et moi je peux le prouver je peux y est
en hausse en juin dit sans nom autant
écouté mon avis il ya malentendu entre
nous on vous affirmer que je vous ai dit
je vous aime
bondues à je viens vous quoi j'ai
demandé dit pas pourquoi mon coeur
n'aurait-il pas le droit d'avoir ses
préférences après une touche parfait
pour des bus était mieux que tout ce que
je viens vous ne voyez pas ici de 70 ans
vous êtes également retourné bien les
vrais rois
c'est une qualité pour les médecins et
les femmes voyez-vous ont tout dans le
coeur une corde qui vibre impôts ici à
ben vous êtes bien vous avez eu le temps
de jeter un oeil sur mon dernier volume
les larmes du coeur est non alors qu'il
est un nom à ce que vous ayez pris dans
ma pensée dans mon esprit un ascendant
plus grand que le commun des mortels il
ya une place pour toutes les infections
qu il est assez grand pour que la part
que l'on donne à l'afp ne viennent pas
en ligne et sur la part de doute mais si
la femme peut disposer de son futur
l'épousa elle ne peut pas disposer de
leurs femmes car les bouges n'appartient
qu'à son mari n'en dit pas de mal c'est
votre ami usher que c'est mon ami et
même il vaut mieux vous allez il a
confiance en moi lui c'est comme ça que
les rondes et son amitié comme man mais
je laime moi non je vous aime a compté
mais je lève lui brave ami il vous
admettrez que je le trouve
non ça c'est un autre point de vue aucun
porte tant que je croirai que mon mari
tient son serment moi je ne trahirai pas
le mien
avec messieurs les anglais tirez les
premiers que demain seulement il me soit
prouvé que mon mari me tombe qu'il a une
liaison annonce à ça je vous jure que
c'est moi qui vous et qui vous dira
morissette manger frais au léontine et
comme je sais très bien que c'est une
hypothèse tout à fait impossible sans
évidemment aux caisses qu'il a lu ce
cadeau par la chasse ce sont les deux
seuls exercices gymniques qu'il se
permette à la nation celle ci est encore
la chasse pour la chasse où il ya des
maris qui ont l'air d'aimer la chasse et
puis pas du tout ce sont des moyens pour
aller courir la prétentaine et je vais à
la chasse et puis une fois dehors il va
y avoir renoncé
j'ai bien réfléchi quelques fois je me
disais est ce que par hasard du châtel
et ben non vous savez non il suffisait
de le voir janvier de la chasse ouais il
faut parfaitement convaincue de la
pureté de sa conscience
non mon cher ami mais ce qu'il y avait
de ces choses mais tellement énorme que
je me disais les six du chatel avait
vraiment quelque chose à se reprocher
non y'a que c'est bon de qu'ils ne
feraient pas au coin mais de quelque
chose voulais vous parler
je sais pas vous tenez l'autre jour par
exemple il vous a rapporté une bourriche
de lièvre de la pape et bien et bien il
ya un fait connu que oui dlabaja pas
d'hier où il ya dédié vient pas de lapin
et comment savez-vous st alizée la
zoologie il n'y a qu'un seul endroit où
ces deux rongeurs se trouvent réunies ce
qui est peut-être là qu'il est allé les
cherche si c'est possible c'est chez le
marchand de gibier wim wenders habitants
qui vous prétendez mon ami mais laissez
moi dormir là dans ma confiance ridicule
mais j'aurai une explication avec du
soleil à monture
on ne fait surtout pas ça mais puisque
je vous ai dit que j'étais intimement
persuadée de l'innocence de mon ami du
chanteur alors mon dieu si je vais pas
été intimement père se met jamais je
n'aurais était vous raconter elle est
soit on croque sais pas ce que ça vous a
échappé
mais les autres je vous assure que non
grata n'est pas là
je répare des cas on n'allait pas vide
et que j'aime j'ai aimé ça et non et oui
ça va bien ça va bien mais il semble que
tu m'as fut certainement mais depuis
tout à l'heure
bon allez adieu adieu c'est ça il aurait
dû s'équipent le nord venu un parapluie
que gmac a fêté ce qui va on dirait
qu'il a reçu un peu de marques au rôle
de garçon bah ça viendrait aussi ce que
tu as qu'est ce que tu as qu'est-ce que
vous avez tous les deux j'ai que je
viens de prendre une leçon de
sophrologie
une leçon qui m'a édifié au nom à saana
prix de ces choses capital que nous
sommes mariés ne devrait jamais ignoré
hessel c'est cool il ya des lapins eniac
de lierre houllier dtn il ya pas de la
peine voilà une chose intéressante à
savoir c'est sûrement qu'une croix car
il est probable que si tu l'avais
chiffre a même dû n'aurait pas apporté
de tâches à une opposition la paye assez
pour moi tu te dis seulement moi je ne
savais bien n'est ce pas je croyais que
la paella est comme ça 67 des femmes
on ne vous apprend rien pouvant mais
heureusement jamais auprès de moi un
homme instruit maurice
c'est lui qui convienne à mentir dans le
malawi la vessie les sports lorsqu'il
m'a éclairé sur la conduite de mon
arrivée mon bébé mais par des coulées
passé avec ses cours soit logique il va
mettre martel en tête
il n'y a pas de raisons tu m'entends pas
de raison et bien prouve le mois à trois
qu'il n'y a pas de troubles et moi si tu
peux
au cinéma le ton amie madame chapeau est
brouillée je crois avec madame de
fontenay
je suis en plein match ardèche 10 est
brouillé avec pas d'homme de fonds tarp
par conséquent elle ne se voit pas
naturellement quand elle continue de
voir comment fais-tu bien bas la vache
et c'est bon alors je dis ravira les
lapins je ne les ai pas quitter donc
tant qu'on vient tu vas trouver
blanchard dès la fin du set et rythm and
jardin et madame de fontenay lors du sac
habite madame de fontenay
après ben voilà là prêt et moi améliore
ses brames de frontenac et mais là pas
c'est madame charest quoi qu'est ce que
tu racontes que tu lui as et madame de
fontenay est absolument autrement dit
quand je veux chasser du liège je vais
ou j'y le guerre et quand je veux
chasser du lapin tu les as et madame
chardin est naturellement et moi qui te
soupçonne and broad suite est folle
c'est où es tu mériterais bien aidé en
soupçonner tout marron bon tu ne
soupçonnerait pas un étranger et qui
soupçonne son mari mais c'est la faute
morisset c'est lui qui m'a mis martel en
tête 6 et 11
alors avec store de l'appeler habib sy
au l'animal mais c'est pour ça que c'en
est allé si troublée il en a même oublié
son chapeau il avait perdu là tu as et
justine arrête de faire de son chapeau
ou moins tu promets que tu n'auras plus
de ces idées folles non embrasse moi là
et maintenant allons visiter ma
garde-robe pour prendre vraiment au
costume de chassenon j'ai besoin d'aller
sonner
il va retrouver sa tête sans son je te
disais tu as fini par s'en apercevoir
mais dix dont j'ai un compte à régler
avec toi qu'est ce que tu as été
raconter à ma femme noire oui avec des
lianes vettel a pas une façon de faire
croire que mes chasse c'était de la
balançoire - o
voici donc comment madame non au
contraire c'est moi qui veut des zecs et
enfin vous savez bien mais c'est que si
tu avais vu madame
en attendant mais surtout je t'en prie
ne va pas croire moi lui faire supposer
qu on
on va rencontrer moi qui prenait la
défense du bien à bord mais
tranquillisez vous mon mari m'a tout
expliqué ah oui avant au brassus
présentant et ben vous voyez bien comme
si tu avais vu madame elle s'imaginait
déjà que parce que des livres et les
lapins mais je lui disais qu'est-ce que
ça prouve les lièvres et lapins de
spacek les femmes
vous voyez bien comme c'est fait les
lièvres 7 et madame de fortune ac mais
voyons c'est évident et les lapins
c'était madame chars mais voyons tout ça
est très claire les lièvres c'était
madame de fontenay de frontenac elle est
là bas c'était madame un char 100 char
des voiles a annoncé bon et une autre
fois des vitres à de jeter le trouble
dans mon village pour faire mon retour
des auditions si j'avais pu prévoir sans
vouloir mois pouvant fondre voilà comme
je t'en veux
je suis fait entrer dans ma chambre un
peu par rapport à monter mon fusil
vous allez voir ses vêtements mais avis
c'est un nouveau tiger meet ailleurs des
gens au chic
je suis kabyle monde veut contrôler ses
coûts dit ton neveu gontran fait les
honneurs à son tailleur cas
l'institution qu'il prépare au
baccalauréat il a le baccalauréat rectif
ce garçon flée ont peut-être un crétin
et en même temps un pur et à nîmes
ça va même très bien ensemble la pure
prête à tuer a dit nous allons voir ce
effectivement baissé ça oui le zune à
toi si tu t'ennuies pro livre alors je
te remercie pour leur répondait au
niveau des coeurs d'artichauts comment
les larmes du coeur c'est sacha guitry
dit claire tu sais je ne vais pas lui
mais je n'ai ranger à rabat c'est déjà
ça dérange est sur la table du salon
comme ça des gens je feuillette ça fait
toujours d'arrêter là avec mercy coeur
d'artichaut coeur d'artichaut et voit
partir les juges et fenêtres au nom
cette messe est dite mais je vous
demande un peu mais quelle idée d'aller
raconter ça son mari pour les lièvres
donner la parole à l'ats on veut lui
rendre service à gauche au sein de ces
histoires aux pauvres n'est pas solide
les larmes du coeur ses chances et ça
qu'il appelle le mettre sur la table du
salon
il entame son secrétaire mon prochain
bouquin où les larmes du coeur par
gustave morrissey ancien interne des
hôpitaux de paris
non mais je vous demande à un peu une
édition deluxe ce paquet de hollande
vandal rats ont dit on regarde qu'est ce
que tu penses de ce pantalon
ah ah oui il est jeune et très jolie oui
les jolies on vient de faire le paria
montrant elle s'est tout dit dans mon
propos je te remercie pour la façon dont
tu as rangé mon livre la trouver oui
sous le choc la terre
ah oui oui en effet et c'est moi qui
l'ait mis pour remplacer le pied j'avais
rien d'autre sous la main comme quoi un
livre certes quelquefois à quelque chose
mais c'est pas pour ça que je les écris
moi qui ai pris la peine de te dédié une
de mes meilleures favre a vraiment pour
le cas plus fin de mon honneur il ya une
page qui met dédié à ce stade est ouvert
je leur ai vu âge 91
j'ai intitulé ça navrant dit jeudi c'est
le titre du sunshine en france à
justinien du chanteur merci à me crois
moi la vie est bien une chimère
aussi quand je te vois qu est malgré
tout cela je me dis le cher homme est
heureux et prospère il ne pense donc pas
qu'un jour son tour viendra
donc tu es gay toi et c'est pour moi dès
lors une tristesse amer qui me crise pas
penser que tout être sans fard je ne
suis plus te voir sans me dire misère
vous serez chez moi quand il ne sera
plus là haut mais qui m'embête c'est
toujours en tête avec une avance non
sinon je te dis sinon ses commencements
du verre non je ne suis pas à croire à
la fin éternel je rêve d'une autre vie
est plus douce et plus belles qui nous
attend après dans un monde plus beau
dimanche rien allons comme ça par mon
dieu c'est un sonnet mais bon ça m'est
égal on joue le maintien n'allons pas ce
que je vais dire les seigneurs m'attend
va donc je serais désolé de te retenir
oui et j'ai pas de temps à perdre à
cause de leur sang ça mais je te
remercie tu sais que tu trouves que mon
pantalon un poème
oui et je me disais donc que nantes on
lui reprocher c'est ça retourner à
thézan tournure c'est con affaires
marchent en dessous mais nul on qu'on a
pu pénétrer ce mystère
ce qui pourrait par mais ne peuvent plus
le faire et c'est là le secret que garde
le tout rend beau que c'est beau
quelque chose de beau là dedans il ya un
souffle beau bon je serai pas de moi je
dirais aussi bien c'est même pas fou
paix enfin je vous demande pas de me
lire il aurait quand même pu couper les
pages ne serait ce que par politesse
franchement rien ses valises et un
coffre est dans vacances et voilà tout
ça on vous rabattre fait relâche quoi je
dis mon four à battre fait relâche
autrement dit mon institution est en
congé au mont fouras va te faire l'offre
non mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire de
mon temps nous le disions la guimbarde
des boucles tout simplement est ce que
vous voulez ce sont les évolutions de la
langue française
dites moi mon oncle n'est pas là si à
côté ils essayent votre pantalon
comment ils essayent mon prénom oui
enfin un pareil à celui là ah c'est ça
il me copie avant ça ben voilà il est
avec son tailleur si vous voulez le voir
oh vous savez je veux le voir et à côté
de ça je ne suis pas pressé non je viens
pour le taper
voici vous comprenez le taper ou frapper
votre famille mais non je voudrais qu'il
me près de 500 francs baup est bien là
et je leur dois déjà 6
voilà le chiendent vous entretenez dans
des demoiselles
home est une merveille monsieur maurice
est un vrai creuse
ces jeunes c'est frais ça n'a pas encore
roulé louis d'un jeu ne compte pas son
vieux n'est-ce pas qu'est ce qu'un vieux
ses études quantité négligeable
il est là pour commanditer la sphère
voile est scellé pour ça que ma petite
amie m'a bien dit si jamais mon singe
survient fourtoy dans le placard il
paraît qu'il tient être le seul cet
homme est-il drôles ou est-ce qu'il me
gène nommé par bleus et vous l'avez vous
rencontrée cette merveille au
mont-de-piété oui et langage et des
bijoux de famille moi je mettais ma
montre au cloud haras de cette
similitude de situation là qui notre
rapprochement nous nous et madame chan
homeaway juliette ce matin
le soir même elle ne remet tait la clé
de son appartement et de son coeur et
depuis je vais la voir tous les
dimanches
quand je ne suis pas consigné comme
dimanche dernier par exemple au
freestyle mon télégramme que j'oubliais
pour la prévenir de ma visite de ce soir
battez les heureuses à quinze jours
d'abstinence
parce que le vieux n'est-ce pas ah bon 1
le vieux et où les fourrés non c'est pas
à cette année c'est une garantie que
j'apporte à mon oncle s'il veut me
prêter mais 500 francs si vous donner
des garanties mesdames c'est un effet
que j'ai préparé à tout hasard
bonjour de ma majorité je paierai rendu
chanter de la somme de 500 francs valeur
reçues compte c'est ça votre garate
maintien ça vaut de l'argent voilà la
dépêche
je vais l'envoyer portée par la bonne le
monde on s'était bien le taper mon nom
que si je pouvais éviter cette corvée ça
ne vous dirai rien à vous par hasard de
me prêter 500 francs man ça me dirait
rien du tout je vous aurais donné mon
billet oui c'est bien mais non oui oh je
pensais bien je vous disais ça par
acquis de conscience à hawaï et non
c'est monsieur six mois pouvez-vous
faire porter cette dépêche à la poste
cette dépêche même allure ben les
voitures qui inventent rude à tête je
vous demande pas de là les roulements de
la porte et bien messieurs il ya 19 mois
là bas un sou vous garderez le reste
mais ça me fera pas de mal ça me remet
sur le pied tenez voilà duchatel vous
allez pouvoir présenter votre heure
était déjà en hausse à mambé
et voilà je suis prêt bonjour attentes
mon entretien et sexy vrai vous avez mon
portable et il paraît il paraît moins
évident ou de copier ou singuliers pas
gentil de les raconter avec marie a plus
jamais rien moi ça festif aux gens avec
des pêches mois teva l'espadon
tranquille voyons ah ça y est ce qui a
attiré e en bac voit la food and on and
on a pas celui-là prend victor hugo bon
gros bras
est dit dans mes enfants quelle heure
est il
cinq personnes ont déjà mangé c'est
kirby soir moi je ne veux retenir le
papa je ne crois pas mais
s'empresse-t-il de coltan si je
reprendrai 21h55 eh oui précisément pour
le dira que l'homme comme attendant là
car je veux te dire que qu'on descende
mensonges et les magasins car entre eux
deux eh bien nous n'abandonnons pas la
question
quand il aura fini d'écrire à 6 heures à
la maison d'or soit 0,2 zizi je signe
physique parce que elle m'appelle
toujours visé dans la maison à me
connaître ce nom là pendant qu'un voile
à soyaux j'ai d'argent il pourra ainsi
la mort ce blog je vous vois justement
compte et l'ailier de bord oui je je
vous serais obligé si vous pouviez me
donner 500 francs mois après quand même
en moi non mon ami non inutile de parler
de l'emprunt je ne peux prêtre est plus
un sou du bois se sent fort eh bien ça
suffit mais non que je ne comprends pas
pourquoi vous me faites tous ces
discours je vous demande pas un cadeau
je vous vois justement des billets de
100 francs dans la main et je vous
demande simplement de m'en donner cinq
contre un billet un excellent billet de
500 euros
c'est que changer une demande ça avec
plaisir maintenant alors 2 3 et voilà 5
500 francs merci pendant prés et voilà
notre billet c'est que ça au jour de ma
majorité
donnant donnant on n'a pas ça non vous
avez accepté mon nom ça ne me regarde
pas un premier temps similaire donc tout
le parcours dauphiné
bon ce profond en voit dans les films ou
des prêts qu'ils te la fait endosser
d'ici là nous compterons icône a perdu à
monsieur cleese et 500 francs or la
suite à l'essai de garantie mais elle ne
vaut rien sans garantie tant à l'avant
qu'à rentrer je te vole haut mais je
remplacerais relationnel allons bon
pièce qui vient là je suis pas tendre à
se voir bas qui est celle à qui son nom
bon ben ça ne fait rien pour recevoir
les routines moi je file ton descendu
mon 5 oui mais c'est bien non
adieu matches amicaux en bien car deux
accidents il descend avec moi à maurice
allais de mai la voiture seulement alors
je me sauve et dans une heure et demie
une routine quand l'apport d'une sonnera
7h tu pourras te dire mon mari est à
dire en cours dans les terres de son ami
casas et saad y est léontine qua non là
salon wii la madame monsieur cassagnoles
hamada
je suis bien heureux de vous voir
comment va du show tel sens qu'est ce
que ça signifie
il n'est pas là vous avez peut-être des
cirés lui parler il ya six langues
allemand il y à l'autre je voudrais en
profiter pour les choses personnelles un
conseil a dû demander d'ailleurs je peux
vous confier ça vous savez que je vis
séparé de ma femme
et comme en plus grand désir serait de
divorce et oui en effet en effet il ne
manquait qu'un grief et bien justement
je venais avancé à ce brave du show tel
qu en fait je le tenais mon regret est
que ce soir je me disposé à faire
surprendre la femme en flagrant délit
d'adultère mais vous c'est un certain
monsieur 6 hidhab alors mes compliments
mais vous me disiez qu'il y avait
longtemps que vous n'aviez pas vu
monsieur chatel ont il ya belle lurette
au moins six mois six mois vous lui
direz que c'est un lâcheur vous avez des
leur encontre et pourtant il me semble à
quelques chasses je crois en charge
moi je ne cherche pas le chasser par
mois moi je n'ai jamais chanté devant
lui il ne chasse pas
oui andré veut dire après ça que vous
aller à la chasse vous viendrez à jouer
la comédie me faire le ponam au
téléphone mais heureusement le masque
est tombé
vous apparaissez avec le marchand de
mort pendant je sais ce que je voulais
savoir comme ça
mais rira bien qui rira dernier je
pouvais reprendre maintenant mais quand
je pense que je ne soupçonnais ria
wimbush bon et je le crois que c'est
français on ne l'attend pas mon tour
j'ai été bonne trop longtemps ça vous la
connaîtrez je suis à peine du talion
et bien moi aussi je vous suffit plus à
bien mois de plus et pour commencer je
vais carrément sac de voyage
je pensais deux jours à la campagne ses
marges cette année
abondamment sur octobre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de l'ombre tout blanc
bon assez pour les rideaux aux canapés
maintenant le canapé c'est généralement
le terrain où s'engagent l'action très
important de la première escarmouche
dépend presque toujours la victoire
double ration ou canapés et adam je
vaporise stratégiquement ainsi tenez là
j'en mets par acquis de conscience parce
qu'à vrai dire quand on est arrivé à
cette phase avec 25 des libations
d'action de grâce
allons j'espère que monsieur maurice est
notre nouveau locataire sera content
j ai lu m'a brisé là pour 16 forme
impériale russe
j'aime les hommes comme ça les hommes
qui ont l'amour ne regarde pas à la
dépense
d'ailleurs y'a t'il rien d'assez cher
pour une femme et mes mots nous sommes
un bienheureux sexe que les jus mois
commentait de la tour du nord quand
j'étais encore du noble faubourg
saint-germain des faiblesses pour un
homme comme celui là au lieu des mets un
numéro de cirque
on a ri ne m'aurait pas pincer je ne
serai pas concierge à l'heure qu'il est
c'est loin tout ça heureux temps ou
séparément burdisso total en dix ans
à quoi bon encore si le proverbe était
vrai il n'est pas de si grande dame que
le multi est une troupe son honneur dit
ho hau wah qu'il ait jamais l'amitié
amitié quart d'heure de jeu vous
cherchez justice que cela infecte ici
est ce qu'un jeune rachat
c'est de l'impérial iata tomber à la
renverse dit on voilà dix minutes je
sonne à la porte en façade et non comme
c'est agréable très attendu à la maison
hauteur avec un ticket pour deux et j'ai
dû manger tout seul et n'attend pas
reçue la dépêche
si monsieur même casting m'a dit mon nom
que zz voilà c'est moi au moment donc
les idées arrivent aujourd'hui à paris
il descend chez moi ainsi qu'à
l'ordinaire vous lui direz que si
j'avais reçu sa dépêche plutôt je lui
aurais conserver ma soirée
malheureusement j'en ai disposez vous
lui remettrez ma clé est privé de factor
comme je n'aurais pas mieux fait de
rester chez elle
la commission annonce saunier je
confirme un salon sony est ce que je
suis moi quand je croyais que marquer ça
ne m'avait dit que si vous descendiez
quelquefois chez elle c'est parce que
vous aviez votre habitation à lons le
saunier 1 aux abois
ah bah oui parfaitement la compagnie
tient à part bleus oui j'habite vous
devez bien vous y ennuie héros mais non
le jardin public la musique militer à
oui pourquoi portez vous toujours votre
fusil quand vous venez à paris ça alors
c'est pas un fusil c'est un nécessaire
de toilette mais c'est comme ça
l'enseigné mais dit on comptait
installer la cocotte très vite ici avec
tout ça morde
mais moi ça lui au bal des voitures mais
elle n'habite plus ici monsieur isi nous
lui avons donné congé vraiment à
monsieur jeune fille n'y ont pas gardé
une locataire comme ça déconsidérer la
maison une demoiselle qui prenait les
collégiens au sevrage
tiens ça me fait penser qu'il faut que
j'aille réclamer une des clés titia son
petit dernier une femme monsieur qui
n'attendait même pas qu'ils puissent
bacheliers pour leur inculquer les
principes de la licence mal semble font
jamais on avait tiré le cordon à celle
d'avant sont patricia se révoltant vous
êtes farouche contre les coptes qui je
les trie les amours veinards jeunes et
de respect moi que pour les écarts des
femmes zone est heureusement depuis le
départ de cette demoiselle je puis dire
hautement que la maison est incroyable
touche gens mariés et même quelques
parfait au gaz et jean baillet tous les
étages
il vient leur dit on ici les nouveaux
locataires
ils sont mariés ne lui non non elle
certainement si j'en juge par le mystère
et les égards dont il entoure le sacré
qu'est ce qui l'a élu il est sympa c'est
un médecin qui se paie une femme mariée
voyez où ça et dire que pendant ce temps
là le mari d'or sur les deux oreilles
quelle mouche alors et on va affronter
ce que je vais voir si madame cassagne
des parents très silencieuse ici on
attendait on revient aux monstres sont
les locataires ni s'ils ont attrapé pour
vous avoir laissé entrer les laissez pas
partir dans la pénombre rencontre on est
entré là je ne rendrai que vous êtes un
mois je vous ai fait venir pour faire
appartements notamment avec moi mais je
vais pas et attendez que je viens de
vous délivrer piste et ça sent le
faussaire
les pépins voici sans terre
et bien entraîné j'ai pas peur nous
allons bon
ai-je dont bien tu aimais demandé mais
qu'est ce qui vous fait peur c'est que
si on voyait tout à fait noir quoi les
femmes tout ça ah non ça c'est rien du
tout la candidature du nord on compte
non c'est ma concierge pas trop coursier
vilas oui madame est une oeuvre est la
tour du nord encore et une latte au qui
a fini par s'effondrer dans une loge de
concierge
on vous raconte pas ça bien eux
contestent nous n'avons plus besoin de
vos services
qu'est ce que c'est que ça on a éternué
damas oui monsieur j'avais oublié cet
homme des parents que j'ai prié de dire
pourquoi appartement mais vous auriez
que le congédier plus tôt mais si
monsieur désir qu'il ne va pas mal
impressionné qu'elle emmenait un instant
dans cette chambre est en jeu devrait
sortir mon pare donc c'est bien fait
vite ce n'est de naissance ou à votre
parent pour sa peine monsieur vous en
sera bien même il sait bien c'est les
jeunes et belles et femmes
en plus oui ah bah c'est pas malheureux
je suis temps frais et moi et c'est
pourtant paul moment c'est martin n'est
pas là pour vous qu'est ce que la part
du docteur frachon appartenant aux as
comme par oc c mon pourboires garde des
commentaires on ne dira pas que je ne
soutiens pas ma famille merci oui bah
voila voila d' eau dont ils sont la wii
et la dame adultère haye sont là c'est
parce que petit ils sont là alors quand
je pense que tout à l'heure on a traduit
sa me fait vraiment pas de quoi faire
petite femme je parie que c'est son
premier coup de canif way or un plus sur
têt fontaine se salueront êtes-vous
hausse mais margueritte cupidon vous
protège moi je suis des fils tôt et je
bouge
j'ai donc que sa basse en espagne et je
sais berson
c'est un dommage ou n'a plus besoin de
voir monsieur maurice m
non merci comtesse alors bienvenue
monsieur matte
oui c'est ça vous aussi au mois léontine
maurice donc vous organe appelé la somme
est là pas mal oui et bien fait comme la
sonnette à les y est aussi allé lait
entier
enfin c'est bien moi qui suis là devant
vous mais je n'ose y croire moi même
laissez-moi vous regardez laissez-moi
vous serrer contre moi laissez moi vous
embrasse merci pour me dire que c'est
fou que c'est bien ou que j'ai désiré
par l'entente deux autres est pendant
tant de maurice une grande folie que je
fais là une fois dit mais en quoi en
quoi hautement tout bon c'est qu'alors
présent je suis encore une femme honnête
et que deux mais vous serai encore
demain
à moins que vous n'alliez le raconter à
tout le monde et bien l'or mais qu'est
ce donc je vous prie que l'honnêteté des
femmes
c'est l'opinion publique et bien nous
n'avons qu'à ne pas la mettre au courant
de nos petites affaires
l'opinion publique et voilà que nous
importe le reste
avez vous déjà oublié cette lettre que
vous m'avez écrite tantôt dans un élan
généreux banon sera sec dans un élan de
rage généreuse à cette lettre qui va
vous faire le paradis 7 l'heure où la
vie comme on si je l'aimé je gâchais
l'adverbe sur mon cas puisque la voir
voilà au coeur
le choeur est partout ah oui la voilà
cette lettre tel que vous l'avez écrit a
naturellement cette belle langue
migrants des simples à la fois celle qui
vient de là comme la lettre que mon ami
je n'ai qu'une parole à l'heure qu'il
est il n'y a plus d'obstacle entre nous
comme c'est comme-ci éloquent
l'éloquence de la concision et la
concision éloquence et puis libre de moi
même c'est à vous que je m'engage voilà
ce que vous avez et après qu'est ce que
j'ai ajouté après enfin c'est sans
importance
on dit que vous bien que jeune agi de la
sorte que parce qu'il a bien voulu que
parce qu'il met ça c'est la petite
concession à l'amour-propre féminin
croyez qu après m'avoir et crise vous
voudriez revenir en arrière alors c'est
trop tard les routines est-ce que tout
tout autour de nous nous invite pas
l'amour santé santé ses parfums qui vous
engourdissent d'ardentes volupté c'est
vrai ça vous voyez voyez ces petites
tables à deux couverts on nous attend le
souper inséparables détendre entrevue
pourrait perdre mon mari qui adore
eh ben il en aura pas regardez regardez
cette lumière discret pur de promesses
et de mystère dans cette demie clarté
que nous ferons plus faible encore geste
assez pour nous aimer mais pas assez
pour nous voir mais la mèche à la
hauteur de la situation et la lune la
lune elle-même qui se met de la partie
une confidente des amoureux bravo claire
regarde le bel astre des nuits
vous avez aval oui à bâle contre fait
tout le tour de la maison en léventine
nous voilà comme roméo juliette dans la
seine du val froid avec seulement vu
très sérieux et là c'est roméo et
juliette en hiver et la voilà là c'est
le pourquoi et comment on essaie le aura
non là bas ça c'est comme en chirurgie
il faut pas installer les instruments à
l'avance allons voyons les consignes
mais les ont-ils mais qu'est ce que je
vois avoue pleurer vous tremblez quoi il
me semble que je me remets à riverains
mais aussi le soir de son mariage
on était la seule près de moi ou il me
tenait des propos d'amour homme est
alors d'un coup le nikon l'armée à elle
dans un élan passionné ensea c'est lui
mon ami c'est dégoûtant rappellerai ce
qu'il est peut-être la srepen amputer
les encres et ne me demandez pas tout le
temps de votre mari enfin aussi oui mais
vous êtes tellement présent à l'esprit
que je sois au moins pour le voir tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui mais au contraire
je veux vous en parler parce qu'après
tout sa conduite était indigne mais vous
ne pensez donc pas qu'en ce moment
peut-être il est en train de faire à une
autre les serments qui ne vous a pas plu
c'est vrai le me citez vous voyez des
scrupules à une maîtresse et bien moi
j'ai un amant voir et il embrasse
l'infidèle où il la serre dans ses bras
on va alors serré servait d'abri la wii
étonné il a raison bravo va bien dit si
c'est pas un disque à pau et tenait mal
acceptée elle est là présent qu'ils
verront cb non ah oui et bat léontine
toute ma vie pour ce moment dit vrai
j'ai soif
elle a soif là surtout voulait voir
quelque chose ou n'apportaient pas du
centre du champagne mais bien celle où
est-il le cheval ça y est la mère à tous
à oublier le champagne
la foire on sait au droit vous n'avez
pas soit venons moi je n'ai soif que de
toi je n'ai soif de ton amour grise et à
botter ivre de ton sourire mon amour
infini mines les me dévore c'est ça des
verts parlement pourrait ce ton regard
de feu jeu sans enjeu tado tout mon
corps frissonner d'ardentes volume allez
allez après à forest à ben j'ai fait que
ces quatre là
on continue par l'envers je sois que je
ne peux pas traîné à elle ne peut pas me
résiste qui est là c'est la comtesse et
la tour est bien entré bien qu'on ait
soit vais vous la terre vous préparez un
souper vous mettez pas de champagne
non si vous avez des fêtes comme pour
vous moi de champagne simple fait mal à
l'estomac
si on fait intervenir l'hygiène mais ce
qu'il y a des épanchements possible au
bordeaux annecy motion un peu tout de
même du champagne en a deux bouteilles
dans la chambre à côté sur la dernière
planche du bay mais je crois bien que
j'en veux pas que c'est facile je laisse
aller au bout non non non non c'est trop
pour vous jouerez plus vite fait moi
même toit les instants compagnie amateur
bien mais le plus grisé de ton sourire
vivre de ta beauté mon amour infini
mobile me dévore willem dévore pas vous
en moi voilà nos comme il faut monsieur
maurice opa vous voulez certes avec un
homme comme ça je prends prend une
feinte du monde se permettent une
faiblesse c'est pour qu'il divulgue
c'est un mode beast une réflexion
générale pour moi si vous voulez madame
pour moi dans le grand encore a été
justement de favoriser un jour un homme
qui n'était pas de mon rang non vraiment
ça m'a coûté ma position dans le monde
ça va là parce que le monde
il vous pardonne une mauvaise conduite
mais il ne vous pardonne pas scandale
mise à l'index par le faubourg
saint-germain chassé par mon mari
voilà où j'en suis arrivé aujourd'hui
pour compte est donc été dit dans cette
eau il était d'auteur au cirque fernando
et qu'il possible dont tous moi madame
il était si beau je me rappelle encore
le jour où je vis pour la première fois
j'étais au stade de première avec mon
mari au il avait teinte or à laisser
votre mari avait 1 1
mon mari renom contraire lui ça rentrait
non le docteur quel corps au fond
fallait le voir dans sa cage pour les
animaux errants
cet homme au comme il doit bien taper
sur une femme
alors ben ami presse à moi mais ne
parlez pas un malade d'une chose que
vous ne connaissez pas quinze jours plus
tard ce don terre de mon coeur me
conduisait dans une petite garçonnière
aussi élégante et parfumé que celle ci
vient d'être dotée cette année
alors n'ayez jamais de faiblesse pour
ados en hauteur de chez père landes mais
je n'en est pas là dedans aussi
aussi il serait ce trop vous approuvez
avoir choisi un galant tôt comme
monsieur maurice je me rue ce n'est pas
rien de ce que vous pensez bien à bien
non la plaine hôtel ibis fait s'appuyer
non rubinstein beach boys nous avons
fait souvent de la musique ensemble
non quand aux abords l'année que dans sa
main et je dois dire que depuis que je
suis concierge monsieur rubinstein ne
mets plus les pieds chez moi non madame
vous permettez c'est à dire toi demain
aux eaux très volontiers totale et sans
merci bien à la merci bien à la moria
au tessin
je n'ai pas trouvé le temps jusqu'à dix
jours les deux feintes et ben quoi allez
donc des salles et dont je fais ça moi
même c'est bien monsieur parler c'est
merci bien
c'est trop difficile parfois comtesse
lit bien longtemps que cette histoire
vous est arrivé avec votre droite on y
aura douze ans à l'immaculée conception
dans tout le monde savait raconter fait
de voir passer en pareille situation
avant par les sk plus bêtes là dans
cette pièce banale auxquels je me suis
laissé prendre avec moi
le départ simulés mais le mari qui va à
la chasse et ça c'est vieux jeu à la
chose son mari aussi tous ces mails
qu'il n'y allait pas à la chasse un
prétexte pour aller chez sa mère
le foyer aux femmes et non mais on n'est
pas du tout quant à marie va chez sa
maîtresse
il dit qu'il va au cirque le sait le
cliché mais quand il dit qu'il va à la
chasse
cela ne prouve pas qu'il a une maîtresse
non ça prouve qu'il se méfie de sa forme
et qu'il allait trancher un drap bien
pour la pince et non je n'avais pas
envisagé la chose sur ce jour cependant
madame maria déjà prétexté comme ça
plusieurs fois qu'il allait dans la
chance ça prouve que ces premières
enquêtes n'ont pas abouti et qui droit
commun
morrissey s'est parfois de mais qu'est
ce qu'il ya chapeau moto je ne veux pas
rester une seconde depuis 107
appartements se mêler aux films que si
vous prendre me prend je ne prends que
vous avez abusé de la situation
on me fera croire des choses que vous
n'avez même pas pu me prouvez moi royer
mais que dieu merci je n'ai rien à me
reprocher que je suis fidèle à mon mari
soit ça par exemple là aussi de mes
fidèles
le pauvre chéri au barça c'est trop fort
comment quand il va chez sa maîtresse en
vous faisant droit qu'il va à la chaleur
aux dons quand on va chez sa maîtresse
ont dit qu'on va au cercle tout le monde
sait ça on ne vit pas qu'on va à la
chasse aux oeufs le cercle la chasse à
monsieur non la chasse ça signifie que
le mari a des soupçons sur sa femme
qu'il fait semblant de s'en aller pour
revenir et la ps mais où avez vous pris
fort et donc à la contester a voulu dire
akwaba moi c'est vous c'est vous qui
l'avez dit ça j'ai dit j'ai dit que ça
avait de quoi vous mêlez-vous mais qui
est-ce qui vous demande quelque chose à
vous monsieur si j'avais pu frais vase
l'atome en garde
mais l'essai dont la porte est
tranquille et en dehors de tout ça je
m'en allais vachement d'aller vous
n'avez pas du tout mais jamais de la vie
je découvre filet vous me sens des
filets allez vous emmener à monsieur
maurice il ya eu comme un vrai brouillon
léontine ce n'est pas sérieux
ce n'est pas l'essentiel on l'a vu avec
les ce qui vous prend choc était
tranquille echaml parfaitement disposés
oui ça non si je vais chercher le
tire-bouchon je reviens crack changement
complet vous trépignez vous voulez vous
en aller parfaitement quelles bonnes
raisons pouvez vous me donner mais je
n'ai pas de bonnes raisons a donné je
m'en allais je m'en allais voilà tout je
suis libre je serai certainement non
vous n'êtes pas libre et vous m'avez
donné votre iphone et votre parole c'est
sacré c'est là bas c'est bien ça qui
m'est égal d'ailleurs vous m'avez donné
une mission à rentrer cette frange des
choix compliqués ministère jusqu'au bout
n'a pas ministère qui tient au
gouvernement c'est facile ici ce n'est
pas la même chose
vous allez voir que vous allez on qu'il
m'avait pas enfin mieux c'est de la
cruauté
on les entiers de moi qui vous aiment
tant aussi je vous aime grisé de ton
sourire vivre de ta beauté
il y en a quatre hommes se départissent
vous me disiez que vous ne pouvez pas
résister quand je vous parlais en faire
maintenant je trouve je peux et la côte
d'alerté vous allez rester là quoi de la
violence puisqu'il faut on employait
vous oublier qu'en pénétrant sous ce
toit ou avait confié de ce fait le soin
de votre réputation et j'entends la
défendre jusqu'au bout et cela même
contre vous même contre moi à oui contre
vous même pour vos gens pour tout le
monde
vous êtes à la campagne chez votre
marraine et bien vous devez y rester
c'est votre marraine si vous ne voulez
pas que tout le monde comprenne que
votre marraine c'est une vieille
histoire sans fin alors là vous verrez
les caméras une fois deux fois
vous ne voulez pas mis ces partis non
non et non c'est très bien passé la nuit
sur ce cas et moi sur cette surface à
cocodrie
ça m'en souviens 27 articles ou non mais
une nuit d'amour passée chacun sur une
chaîne 100 en prie vous êtes chez vous
vous avez votre oeil les coûts chez lui
ou pas mais vous c'est bien gérée dans
la paix sans conditions il ya bien un
fauteuil mitchell sachez le le
souffrirait pas grave c'est vous qui
prendrait cette chambre mois couché dans
votre lecteur sache ap
mais selon moi voyons sans moi j'espère
dit mais ben alors on met ça en vous
comme avec vous le résultat sera à nîmes
ça dépend du point de vue auquel on
pense
m'installerai apprenti chez sgs et je
dormirai comme ça je ne dormirai pas du
tout ce sera pas puni et tout ça pour
cette concierge au nom mais ça devant
quelque chose une couverture oui bah oui
je veux bien mais vous savez vous avez
120 kw à l'avant il fait apprendre nous
le temps nous a livré hier au meurtre
merci en voilà une scène c'est délicat
ce qu'elle fait là notre maître et puis
ensuite aux non non non je suis bon
garçon mais quand même si elle doit
faire ton histoire y en a d'autres parce
qu'au fond elle est prêt si jolie que ça
passe et jolie ksa
ah bah il fera chaud quand on me
reprends bras est-ce que celle des
concerts où allez vous en vous
m'entendez allez-vous-en jour via ses
vues mais monsieur c'est le locataire
d'à côté votre voisin de palier qui
m'envoient vers vous eh ben je m'en
fiche je le connais pas mais je sais
bien seulement sa nièce vient d'avoir
une attaque de nerfs et demi c'est que
vous êtes médecin et bien des trucs que
je ne suis pas médecin de nuit et
maintenant filet vous m'entendez filet
si je ne tiens pas à ce que vous
compliquer la situation aucun avantage à
lui tiré non mais quel culot ce voisin
mais je m'en fiche mois de sa nièce et
son attaque de nerfs oh qu'est ce que
vous cherchez vous allumez le feu place
aux mines et n'est pas choix bien jeune
quel caractère
quel caractère mode et son mari sont
pauvres maric est obligé de vivre avec
elle
aubin jeu là encore qui est là
je vais l'envoyer promener seins alors
qu'est ce que vous voulez y ont duré du
chanteur
on n'entre pas
en tuer sa femme qui est là verdict on
attend pas
maurice et du cher oh oh celle là il
faut quand même y avait 18 était passé
que je viens de jouer ce soir voilà
alors c'est toi médecin c'était le
médecin mon dieu et sa femme et au team
tennis la marche et la trappe de la
cheminée de pièces clés par laser vient
de céder romana leur palace massif des
ramoneurs de nuit se fait la nuit ma
tante ne pourra pas sortir au wat eut
poussé le verrou c'était pour la suite
pour toi que la suie entre ici alors mon
cher raconte des histoires avant ou
alors avoué puissant votre fortune - en
quoi y'a pas de mal d'ailleurs je n'ai
qu'à voir ce petit soupir domaines dont
le soupèse jamais il était déjà quand
gervais l'appartement c'était pas
l'appartement garni
dans les gares ni dix appartements 1
allons voyons fédéral qui a choisi
d'abord on me l'a dit que tu as une
liaison avec une femme du monde et tu te
dis ça madame la tour a confié la
concierge et bien oui la sorte allons
donc elle est l'heureuse victimes non
non non non la discrétion bon on voit
trois mois en matière justement à toi tu
as peur que j'ai de dire oh non on
n'aurait pas alors allons l'envoyer
madame cassez
là je suis avec elle 1
enfin bon tout d'abord confiance en moi
attendaient en attendant ce torchon
médecin et je t'en mets ta voisine
madame ka sat qui regardent attaque l'om
en match et bien c'est l'important
phrase non moi j'étais censé la
concierge vous l'envoyer chez pharmacia
je te retrouve six machines à écrire un
conte ramoneur pour soi mais un fait
rien ça fait rire elle va crier il va
entendre sa voir la rejetant en double
aux jeux radieux
[Applaudissements]
ils ont beau jeu suite à moi
oh
et
o o
alors moi je les attends ciel et toi tu
penses tu que je te dis alors à tous de
le faire mais on l'a béni douala
oui voilà hurler on est en train de
semer l'oignin instant au nom du ciel ne
bouge et on ne vous montrez pas il y va
de votre noble qu'est ce que vous dites
je n'ai pas le rendez vous en expliquer
davantage si on sonne n'ouvrira
personnes je m'en vais je reviens je
passais mon manteau et des cendres de la
concierge ya de ça
des scènes de la fleur d'oranger j'ai ce
qu'il faut
bon voyons aussi morisset je suis jeune
il n'est pas encore là oui on remue la
tente
eh ben non voyons
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça ah mon
dieu ça marche
enfin là des idées qui sont rares en
appoint l'égard de madame vous allez
vous brûlez les pompeys parbleu ça peut
être la femme du monde en question ne
craignez rien madame je respecterai
votre incognito
je venais savoir c'est moi c'est
monsieur maurice et en parla à il est
parti même si madame c'est tout ce que
je voulais savoir
désolé de vous avoir dérangé et madame
et bien et l aise devant lui qu'est ce
qui te prend encore a alors dit on voit
du toit était là bas non non oui oui
parfois non immédiate a été oui c'est
fait je les saignées seigner
mais on ne sait pas pour ça ben oui
c'est bien mais quand on est pressé
quand ça lui a pas fait de mal alors
c'est tout ce qu'il faut aller vers des
temps rotary bon je te comprends tu as
deux compères c'était vrai c'est exclure
enfin madame fils bonne chance oui merci
au président on pense à moi je n'y
manquerai pas un jeu sans méchanceté
mon dieu quelle situation qu'est-ce que
je suppose que nous avons partie des
comme en partie que jamais de la vie
mais moins que jamais vous voudriez que
je participe justement si nous partons
il peut les rencontrer que le voir
tandis qu'ici pour moi nous sommes pas
lavés occultes
tu a fermé la porte à double tour voilà
comme ça je pose la clé sur la table de
nuit maintenant personne ne peut plus
j'ai vu tous ces mots c'est un peu court
à tout danger semble intéressant car
trop bon et ben je crois que le mieux
que nous ayons à faire c'est de tâches
et de dormir jusqu'à demain matin
et alors vous pourrez sans risque
regagnez votre domicile comme quelqu'un
qui revient bien tranquillement du
château de sa marionnette et jusque là
dans mon si vous croyez que je vais
pouvoir dormir est attaché mais jeudi
d'en faire autant bonsoir bonsoir au
genou l'a pardonnerai jamais celle là
c'était neurones l'enviro lalalalalala
aucun nous en sommes
la pauvreté va très mal coucher et par
là
par contre moi je sais très bien au
maire prendra vouloir subjugué les
femmes du monde avant aux mondieux à
leur apporter de l'espoir mais personne
ne peut plus entrer
donc c'est la vie alors je peux me
coucher 30
et ben voilà
je ne dirais pas je suis en bonne forme
moi ici elle là bas c'est ce qu'on
appelle une intrigue d'amour et c'est
plutôt de dormir pour imbéciles
au surplus toutes ces émotions là m'ont
brisé
aulas au diable les femmes du monde
oh vous êtes déjà couché madame oui
puisque j'ai que ça à faire ah le jour
où vous ne négligerait vous êtes vous
on veut que vous nous aidiez enfin le
reste vous êtes gagner c'est pour me
dire ça que vous êtes revenu non sur
avenue pour chercher à accous pour
mettre ce matin eh bien vous l'avez
c'est ben beau jeu léo peu vous importe
ce que je pense a mis sur notre chan
khuong je me suis bien conscient je vous
en prie donc tu ne peux pas dormir avec
la conscience du devoir à compte à
l'occar en france en mai après de
grosses couvertures s'inquiéter
cette suppression vous pouvez revenir
après sa visite dans la galerie
non non mais aussi veut dire que vous
êtes un galant tome
il tord aux eaux christique chinois
n'aie pas peur ma petite urbaine c'est
moi montrant
elle ne répond pas elle doit dormir
comme c'est qu'un autre d'avoir sa clé
on peut venir à n'importe quelle heure à
elle va être joliment contente de me
voir
ouais elle dort seul mois elle a l'air
un peu enrhumé pour butelle n'ai pas
peur je vais l'a réveillé par un baiser
une personne qui vous envoie ce n'est
jamais bien l'effrayante aux mails et
fortement rue mais elle a le sommeil du
[Musique]
cet anneau
eh bien non ici olala rien sommes
motivés léontine il est peut-être celle
entre les hautes et très haute savoie
titre le vieil ami du rebelle big dan au
placard je ne sais pas cherchons
cherchons la dans les biberons embrassés
mais vous êtes fous mais puisque je vous
dis qu il m'a embrassé tous il a manqué
de passer par le trou de la serrure de
la porte est fermée les padam regardez
vous même allez je suis pas fou j'ai pas
du délire
j'ai bien senti la fumée mais maintenant
je vous dis que tu avais eu un cauchemar
beauchemin en or alors dame salue on est
mort vous n'êtes pas drôle
on ne fait pas de ses émotions étaient
sur le non pardon et antennes mais j'ai
tellement cru que c'est égal j'aime
mieux ça oui c'est bien moi j'ai vu
autre chose
ah oui quelle nuit chez vous
après d'un brouillard pas du travail
n'ont pas pu s'adapter mais la fête non
plus voyons un deuxième passage es2
cette nuit nous envoyons les boutons et
rivets bébé mais nous n'avons plus
qu'une seule ressource teillé total
alors dû femmes de la tenue et surtout
les ondines surtout jitco fois et
bastien se tient très bien ce qui s'est
mal à entrer est-ce que l'abs au heiva i
venir en vertu de quel mandat vous
forcer ma porte a par ailleurs je vais
vous dit mais tout d'abord pardonnez moi
monsieur et madame de venir vous
déranger une façon aussi intempestives
si le magistrat instrumente l'homme du
monde s'excuse fait c'est bien monsieur
c'est pire ceci dit je viens monsieur ou
plutôt madame à la requête de monsieur
votre mari constaté la présence de
monsieur dans votre domicile à cette
heure avancée de la nuit
mais je ne vous comprends pas je suis
marié et madame et ma femme
oui mais nous là nous la connaissons on
nous répond ça tous les jours comme
galante hommes
j'approuve votre mensonge mais comme
magistrat de vous appeler docteur
morissette et vous madame même adam
morrison ou home pourquoi vous entêtez
nous savons très bien que madame n'est
pas madame morrison madame et madame
cassone madame k sign
au casting il a dit madame vous avez dit
madame il indiqué madame 4o le bon
commissaire au bond de 8,7 en france
monsieur jean cassaigne en face en face
oui monsieur rome est fermé cela
confirme high au second la porte à
droite je me semble que c'est la 3eme
l'escalier un non sens cela va tout
droit
la voilà au moment où toute excuse on se
voit ce que c'est je me serais retourné
sur le palier et aussi ma droite est
devenue ma conquis jeudi par monsieur
ben on ne réveille pas les gens à part
ailleurs pour leur dire sans je suis
désolé monsieur madame continuer je vous
en prie continuez c'est enfin oui c'est
en phase 3 léontine quoi c'est trop tard
besoin de dire 50 ans du commissaire de
police ici alors là vous mettez le
comble à vos frais mais ce que ces neuf
au temps passé des problèmes gaza qui va
jouer envoyez j'aimerais bien ça oui mon
nom tueuse et du show tel qui chez elle
il va se faire pincer par le commissaire
aulas
qu'est-ce que vous avez rien on le
malien olhain
les échos temps vous êtes content de ce
qui arrive
est ce que j'ai l'air dedans c'est là à
mon dieu mon pote alors j'ai oublié mon
pantalon
je ne peux pas vous refaire comme ça au
le pantalon de morrissey je suis sauvé
voilà là là là et maintenant je suis
sauvé voyons jeunes en tant que moyen
douloureux au contrat mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ces gens là non mais non mais
non c'est pas ça france vous encaissez
occasion par m
mais là c'est moi
hugo
pendant mêlant oui monsieur adam est
revenue de la campagne par le premier
train à à l erreur et monsieur passe en
quart d'heure tout art a annoncé mois
via monsieur monsieur voilà madame
madame vous voit lara gut et on est une
épave hausse est de présenter plutôt de
plantes éveiller les soupçons mais vous
n'imaginez pas dans quel état je suis
depuis ce matin moi je me demandais ce
que vous étiez devenu depuis le drame de
cette nuit mon avis je crois que je n'ai
pas si moi-même ce que je devenais sur
le moment je ne comprenais plus vous à
l'esprit la maison senti le souffle la
fête grande vertu second surgissant d'un
placard ça je demande un peu pourquoi
votre g plus jamais le délire
je me suis sauvé comme une folle et je
me suis prouvé je ne sais comment dans
la rue tête du faux bond tout le nom
pour moi par des offrandes et j'aurais
aéré longtemps de la sorte si je n'avais
été rappelé à la réalité par un jeune
blanc bec qui est venu à moi et qui m'a
dit madame je veux francs
je vous demande un peu ce que ça pouvait
faire qu'il va la france
ils cherchent et de la monnaie
non j'ai compris que je ne pouvais pas y
aller comme ça qu'ils leur temps sur les
voies publiques
alors nous on y rentrer chez moi de me
présenter dans un hôtel j'ai loué une
voiture fermée
j'ai dit au chauffeur tourner autour de
la place de l'europe je vous prends le
temps de me prendre pour une folle
le chauffeur et nous avons tourné comme
ça jusqu'au matin au jeu placé tracker
la place du roi du matin quand helm a
édifié sur la conduite de mon mari votre
lettre
non mais quand je pense que vous veniez
me soutenir camaret qui fait semblant
d'aller à la chasse des pauses à marie
qui va chez sa maîtresse mois sacré faut
bien l'avouer là où il est et messieurs
du chant tel chez madame qu'à ce rythme
je souhaitais que ça mais le pire c'est
que ça retombe sur moi commencez votre
mari qui va à la chasse sans permis et
c'est moi qui ai la contravention au ca
par exemple ne s'est plaint de votre
four comme qu'est ce que nous puissions
vous avez vu un instant dans
l'appartement d'à côté vous n'aviez qu'à
vous expliquer que si vous voyez ce
n'est pas l'enfer elle commissaire sûr
quand on parle comme ça au commissaire
il m'a répondu je n'ai pas à entrer dans
ces détails
je suis là pour constater des fins et
non pas pour les raisonner un monsieur
était dans cette chambre avec madame ce
monsieur s'est enfui sans pantalon par
le balcon on l'a rattrapé après dans la
même tenue ce monsieur c'était vous moi
je ne sens pas de là je dresse procès
verbal le res te regarde juste un truc
sur internet insisté mais j'ai pas pu
été pressée elle est dans le monde où ça
au bal de l'hôtel de ville
mais ça ne se passera pas comme ça je
vais de ce pas ses commissaires aux
comptes
tu lui feras convoqué du show telle une
fois en présence tous les deux qu'ils se
dévouent absolument en voiture longue
pourquoi est ce que je me dévouerai à
moi si nous avions été surpris ensemble
tous les deux est ce que votre mari ce
sera dévoué pour nous non bon eh bah
alors c'est très juste
or à moi je sais ce qu'il me reste à
faire le divorce quoi vous vous voulez
parfaitement mais personne est au
courant de mon escapade hier
j'ai dans le rôle et pour commencer
comme je ne veux pas qu'il reste de
trace mon équipe et vous allez me rendre
ma mettre votre lettre vous exigez
parfaitement tout ce que j'avais pu
obtenir de tous alors beaucoup la
chemise
oh mon dieu quoi comment dieu mon dieu
mais quoi elle est dans mon pantalon
elle est dans la poche de mon pantalon
il apprend même dans mon pantalon
nous sommes bien qu'on me demandait
qu'est ce qu'on va faire non non à votre
langue explique de nourriture y est pas
mauvais mais en fait ce que je pouvais
prévoir votre mari prend vraiment au
pantalon
oui bref ayessa merial
mais comment voulez-vous c'est très bien
ce vêtement ne lui appartient pas il
n'aura pas la distraction rescousse bon
eh bah alors vous êtes une femme vous
n'aurez qu'à trouver une explication
avec moi et pas que le que là que les
quelque chose comme ça ce sera les pc
est ce moi vous ne faites que des
maladresses sont avec votre
programmation java celle commise un tel
rôle m'a proposé ça allez allez allez
allez
il est exaspérant cet homme là avec son
imprévoyance enfin quand on a su reçoit
une lettre de femmes une lettre qui peut
la compromettre on ne l'a fort pas dans
la poche de son pantalon il est n'est
pas difficile de se dire qu'est ce qui
arrivera si le mari mais mon portable
enfin ça saute aux yeux non mais non
mais non mais ne réfléchisse à rihanna
qu'est-ce que je raconterai mois ah bon
mari maintenant s'il a trouvé la lettre
que le que là comme dit maurice esch
non ça ne suffira pas je perdrais une
partie de jeux réussis pelle pour une
pareille à qu'on sait comment son nom
bon c'est impossible je viens
d'apercevoir monsieur qui laisse en
pâture monsieur aller tout de suite
d'ouvrir bien madame je verrai tout de
suite il a pris connaissance de la
lettre et c'est parfois nos rues ne sait
rien on ne nous abaisserons massif
d'uchaux tél je vais vous laisser
patauger madame monsieur madame barèges
à léontine mal et on le sait rien
fatigué par nation n'est pas du tout pas
du tout au contraire aux eaux
nous avons fait une chasse super bras
figure toi depuis 7 heures du matin non
j'étais au chaud l'été sochaux jeudi au
chaud dans mes vêtements
mais c'était quand une voiture j'avais
hâte de revenir c'est drôle quand je
suis loin de toi cassagne voulait
absolument garder mais je n'ai rien
voulu entendre
choi dit nous avons chassés cinq heures
ça suffit moi je retourne auprès de ma
petite femme adorée comédien homme et l
bellechasse faisait un temps c'est sans
doute pour ça que tu as changé de
portable un os à huy avait précisément
été aperçu un rebond mais les femmes
voient tous
il est un peu plus et un peu petit wifi
de quoi j'étais trempé alors cassagne se
brade micasa il m'a dit tu ne peux pas
garder ce pantalon là je vais te prêter
un des mineurs sains c'est ça oui mais
oui c'est ça c'est ça y est il n'est pas
tout à fait la taille n'est ce pas mais
plutôt que d'attraper mal bavé
apportez moi dont le pantalon que je
vais tous les jours
mais quelle belle chasse non tu n'as pas
idée
et puis je me suis distinguer qui sait
j'ai été étonnant j'ai fait un certain
doublé un cheval abu dhabi qui filait
comme ça et qui repasse ont fait lever
un coq de bruyère bons lots adjugés tué
cassagne tué avec un sac les nahdhaouis
enfin le vin jaune est gelée stupéfié et
l'egypte il a lui aussi eu naturellement
les deux marcheurs c'est bien pour ça
que tu as sagna a été au mieux pour que
je te montre tout ce que j'ai rapporté
n'a pas une paire décision mais comme en
danger tant cherché je suis trop
curieuse de voir le résultat de tasha
mais tu verras tu arrives j'ai un poids
de moi j'avoue que j'étais dans les
transcendent man ici c'était gagner de
quoi que l'histoire de mon doublé n'a
pas mal fait dans le tableau cp bien
couleur locale décès maurice aussi et
bien dans la note
40 francs chez chevet et j'ai dit oh
vous vendait un an plus tôt j'ai crié
aux vendeurs parce qu'il était sourd
comme un pot
faites moi un joli choix de gibier poils
et plumes
le tout empaqueté dans une bourriche il
m'a soigné ça vous fait tout et dont la
note
l'écriture de ma femme c'est pas ça ah
ah voilà la facture bamba inutile de
laisser traîner des pièces
compromettantes voir le côté mais la
voilà ma chère amie la voilà tu y
trouveras toutes ma chasse et bien sûr
que c'est trop de tâches à ce que j'y
trouverai comment si j'en suis sûr mais
d'un brouillon qui n'a pas été du tout à
la chasse aux bonbons
ça doit te reprendre que millet et
voyons quand je te raconte les exploits
cynégétique
quand je te rapporte du gibier pincer
bourriche nom de n'a pas cette fois
mais où va la lui rendre c'est ce que je
fais et mon dieu oui ça c'est ça l'enjeu
c'est de dire si cet exploit comme iras
tu sais le legi pied par ces temps
orageux l'autre est un mot sont
mécontents dont un enfant dans ma
démarche
voyons les hôtes et d'alès moins jolie
demande du gip dira pas fait dans une
bourriche l'instant appâté dans une
forêt en chine qui ne croient pas au
basket un chat ce n'est qu'un mensonge
parce que tu n'as jamais été remis en
cause
quant à ton ami kassaï non seulement il
n'était pas avec toi mais il n'a jamais
su ce que c'était que la chance de sa
vie
quoique mais ça c'est lui même qui l'a
dit il et on fut pas plus tard qu'hier
tu fais partie on dresse un mois à rome
par exemple
or alors c'est parce que 400 10 nuls
alors tu crois tu ne connais donc pas
castle matin c'est son coup de soleil ne
savions pas qu'il a attrapé un coup de
soleil ray fake et depuis ça lui enlever
la mémoire alors n'est ce pas pu lui
demande s'il va à la chasse
il dit non parbleu il est sincère il ne
se rappelle pas par chasseur lui ah ben
je voudrais qui fut la tient pour le
dire devant moi je voudrais qu'il fut là
et bonjour à temps bonjour je suis ravi
c'est toi
mme boisseau de bons qu'à ça nous avons
chassé ensemble et non et ça va bien
depuis ce matin de plus ce matin depuis
depuis avant-hier jeu cia je sais bien
non mon mari vous demande depuis ce
matin spécialement comme il vous a vu à
la chasse ah oui oui c'est bien un
chasse à chasser mais oui enfin tu te
rappelles mon double est un faux
le populaire et de chevreuils qu'est ce
qui change tu vois il se rappelle très
bien et ont d'ailleurs nous avons vu le
résultat
6 puisant ray mais moi non pas du tout
je croyais en avez vous fait une
hécatombe à vous deux oui avoir tué tout
ça
mais ce n'est pas avec eux la chasse de
mon mari pendant tout dire le pape
benoît
un mélo qui signale à l'aller mais
qu'est ce que tu as fait l'imbécile au
delà puisque vous étiez d'achat semble
avoir mais oui mais oui mais n'ont pas
d'âme
non mais si mais si tu vois je suis ravi
c'est ce que je te disais il ne se
souvient pas c'est son coup de soleil
mais oui naturellement tu te rappelles
pas non plus donc une salle à l'épicerie
targuer la mémoire non il pas tu le sais
triste une infirmité pareil mais qu'est
ce que tu as j'aime bien vos qualités de
quoi me dire à moi ah ça vous avez du
talent mon cher mais vrai il faut vous
ayez une bien mauvaise opinion moi
pourtant ces papiers j'avais des
histoires aussi misérable et honteuse
parce que vous croyez que je ne sais pas
tout ce qu'on pensait que j'imagine que
votre chien sa passe était un prétexte
pour avec les mots fraude el may et ont
le courage au foot je puisse me dire
c'est un homme sans foi oui mais du mois
cette façon les outils laisse moi tu
m'exaspère monsieur mambé
j'aimais aussi c'est la chasse de
messieurs les outils nominé aux biens du
grabuge il ya du grabuge à sa triple
maladroit qui n'est pas pape n ont qu
elle ne comprend rien et 3h de patiner
que tu avais plutôt un prétexte en fait
de la femme que je l'avais dit que
j'allais chez toi pourquoi faire tant
battus en parle parce que je pense que
je peux être un et puis est-ce que ça
trois gars oh oh non non non non non
c'est pas censé voilà un garçon qui
reste des années il sans rire de voir je
m'en fais la libye très commode et il
faut qu'il choisisse juste le jour où je
suis censé être chez lui pour débarquer
dans mon ménage ce que je pouvais sans
voir une si jamais rien mais que diable
quand on a pris l'habitude de te mettre
les pieds chez quelqu'un il me semble
que la première chose à faire avant d'y
retourner
c'est de se dire halte là informons nous
d'abord
viendront pas d'alibi au mari me semble
que ça saute aux yeux ce nom qu'est ce
que tu veux je suis pas sorti un ânon
anormaux tout n'est pas sorcier tu n'as
pas besoin de le dire il ya des gens qui
ont la visite malheureuse comme il rogne
haunt en échange de deux pilotes
enfin qu'est ce que tu me qu'est ce que
tu viens faire ici et bien voilà tu va
peut-être retrouver un discret à ben ça
c'est bien possible oui mais j'ai pris
rendez vous ici avec le commissaire de
police chez moi poulies en voilà des
idées tu vas mettre des commissaires de
police à présent mais comme j'ai pour
habitude le prendre toujours conseil de
toi mais avant tout j'ai le plaisir
notamment symbol
j'ai passé cette nuit mauve homme en
flagrant délit d'adultère
ouah c'est toi qui as fait ce coup là
sur de quoi se mêle-t-il et pourquoi pas
quoi tu as passé ta femme tu as rien
passé du tout du moment abandonné pas la
mort mais pardon c'était justement nous
le tenons là bas vous et l'amant
parfaitement annoncée par voie qui va
nous raconter cela c'est un homme et
mûri c1
maurice est médecin mais lucide il avoué
non fini le coquine race mais son
pantalon le trail son pantalon qu'il a
oublié la saf lui mon pantalon octobre
bouquet et au fait tu ne connais pas un
point fort mais c'est moi et non pas dit
que vous marie 5e n'est pas
non non non je l'aï branché
oui mais qu'est ce que tu me charles ii
que tu ne connais pas testé vie sans toi
à moi je dis sage la vie cajun la bande
décide qu'on a c'est morizet tu ne m'en
voudrez pas des bories ces caniveaux rue
sec quattro avoir eu sept à huit a su
j'ai entendu mon but c'est que tu avais
peut-être pas aperçu m a dit bru 500
sable non mais c'est je connais cruauté
mois alors ce mot hissé non non non non
aucun rapport aucun rapport c'est c'est
mon chemisier en effet je vais et il est
bon aux excellents de voilà enfin que le
fait de jolis coups trop cette fois
c'est le mari était dit que son mari
séka séka sabat may gaza et non voyantes
et toi tu obtiens dog et et ça va bien
oui bon il ne s'agit pas de ça je te
prie dit aimer tout à l'heure je
m'intéresse à tout à l'heure
dinner quoi ah oui oui c'est un
chemisier d'enfance mon cher maurice et
je ne présente plus mon ami casse a
ajouté monsieur est opéable
et maintenant je te prie de me dire mais
j'ai dites le aux rayons étaient pressés
a été pensé je ne vous cacherai pas le
châtiment des tensions de me faire
affaire avant peu et le 12ème de chemise
allons bon
je voudrais avoir quelque chose de bord
dans l'es14 offrant plus qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que ça me fasse comme un les
oublie pas c'est évident qu'est ce que
ça peut lui faire lécher vision on avait
bien suivi et de pantalons qu'il s'agit
et puisque je vous rencontre monsieur je
ne serai pas fâché d'avoir avec vous une
petite conversation et valentine
1 mais non mais non mais donc je vous
dis nous avons mais parce que monsieur
veut me parler
il veut expliquer comment on coupe une
chemise ça ça ne t'intéresse pas d'aller
à l'est pas par l'art des pourquoi
parceque il à me prendre mesures là je
vais mettre tous les atouts
allez allez va par là le commissaire je
t'appellerai contis radar n'oublie pas
non mais non quelle journée à toi à
présent qu est ce que tu as menée ils le
demandent mon pantalon
où est mon pantalon ainsi pour sa de
silva par des balles et voilà qu'on
bataille n'est pas perdue
nos cours d'histoire pour une culotte et
dans les objets les affaires qui étaient
dedans mais le son acer est ce que tu
crois que j'ai barboter dans les poches
enfin nous tenons la lettre mais allons
tout de suite au fait nous des dons tu
t'es bien conduit toi cette nuit moi
c'est us dont il est la cause avec ton
équipe et m bah oui on me l'a dit tu
t'es fait pas un ca batna oui et bien
qu'est ce que tu veux que je te dise mon
programme et c'est bien malheureux mais
ça va encore mieux que si c'était moi
comment ça vaut encore mieux
ah ben tu es bon toi sinon je vais payer
pour les autres
j'entends que tu me tires de la mois
jamais la ville 1 enfin est-ce que ça me
regarde
est ce que c'est de ma faute si tu
t'étais bas c'est quoi comment pour
l'honneur d'une femme dont je suis maman
je risque de me casser le cou en
engendrant des fenêtres en franchissant
du balcon j'accomplis des prodiges
d'héroïsme j'arrive à sauver la
situation
et parce que maladroit vient se jeter en
caleçon dans les jambes des cabinets
avaient pris mon pantalon rwanda
n'étaient pas sur toi europe comme ça
t'apprendra deux premiers avec deux
importantes si l'académie de médecine
savez sans ça c'est trop frais te crois
que ça va en rester là haut je n'en sais
rien je me débrouille toi moi je ne sais
qu'une chose je n'ai pas était pas assez
je ne suis pas parce je ne sors pas pas
en paroles
avait pas encore calmée bonjour routine
quoi
tu me boude toujours moi j'ai bien
d'autres choses en tête
qu'est ce que c'est que ce pantalon
porté sur les cool ça c'est un pantalon
que du show tel marrante mon futur c'est
d'abord ici rendez les pantalons de suka
son nom mais non mais non je les parents
des sommes en jeu mais de le quitter
n'est ce pas je ne savais pas où le
mettre
alors là non je vais jeter sur l'épaule
mais je vais vous répondre que non mais
si mais si les bons lui je songeais donc
pas reconnaître qu'en dit justement je
savais bien que ne lâcherai pas elle est
renversant
eh bien oui et ondines et c'est vrai je
pourrais dissimulé je préfère te le dire
carrément ce pantalon est à maurice
voilà vous voulez vous amener et la
chasse à vous et vous aussi pour la
chasse c'est bien oui là j'avoue tout
puisque aussi bien tout ce que je
pourrai diront rien à cette non je n'ai
pas été à la chasse la plus avec
cassagne qu'avec un autre dit double ipa
meno male madame mais je voulais vous
dire je n'avais pas bien saisi en
question tout à l'heure à propos de la
chasse mais je crois bien que nous avons
chassé en somme il a la main heureuse
mais non voyons tétouan grands qu'est ce
que tu vas affronter avec la chasse au
mans mais non ma femme sait très bien
que nous n'avons pas chasser ensemble
qu'est ce que tu as besoin de dire des
mensonges nous voyons baisser tous les
nommer nos eaux aux eti menteur à
l'essai par l'as jamais je suis aussi
avec toi décès viennent dans ce cas
qu'est-ce qui prient dans ses ébats par
aller tu passerais le spot alors
commissaire mais oui mais oui et la
girouette du maïs du manioc ou non à sky
que pièce j'avais vu un coup de soleil
par un commissaire à assas et revient
une affaire sans importance et sa femme
qui a été pincé en flagrant délit avec
vous avec moi
mais bon qu'est ce qui te fait dire avec
moi en force est ce que le mari serait
là c'était avec moi c'est qu'elle
mettrait saliver devant moi mais je n'ai
pas choisi de mettre à l'honneur une
chose pareille non je t'assure maîtresse
moi j'avais de la vie enfin maurice est
mais je ne sais pas mon ami je ne sais
pas mais si alors pourquoi ces châssis
muet face à face à arras a scellé
c'était une surprise une surprise que je
voulais le faire à la parole une petite
maison au bord de la mer que je pouvais
cloud et vous n'auriez pas fait mystère
il y a une histoire de femmes l'accès
aux mais non je te dis une maison et une
petite maison il n'a pas de fans de
soumah et moi pendant ce temps
j'attendais une araignée confiant quant
au domicile conjugal mais les routes une
hausse et que je suis une femme honnête
et moi je suis une épouse fidèle mois
n'est ce pas paraissait mais oui mais
moi aussi je suis une
je suis un n'est ce pas 25 jamais
cherché à tromper vos narines mois n'est
ce pas morrissey au nom du roi moi je
n'ai jamais songé à combien par mois
n'est ce pas c est vous êtes fidèles
tous les deux est ce que vous faisiez
donc cette nuit son confort
c'est aussi ce qui via ça vous fait peur
ça sent pourquoi pas çà mau 7500 francs
pour vos kiosques
et bien voilà je vais lâcher à ben amos
ah oui et maintenant que l'armé blanche
oui oui quoi ah non je croyais est-ce
qu'ils ont là et maintenant on tasse et
oui on s'est vus on l'a assez vu
oui nous avons imposé tu reviendras plus
tard va m'attendre au salon se donnerait
les 500 francs ya un vieux matin du bon
train vous serez vous cet enfant allait
m'attendre au salon bio au salon elle
aussi a bien ils se rencontreront là
comme ça il ne mettra pas les pieds dans
le plat
oui ça fait on on a sonné on a sonné on
a sonné mais ça peut il être ça moi
c'est c'est monsieur bridoire mais
supprime toi c'est monsieur bridoire tu
connais monsieur ries droit non pas du
tout vous connaissez monsieur brideau
jamais vu ah ah bah moi non plus et
badens fait leur entrée
monsieur madame la commissaire de police
tué le reconnaît lui une femme tue la
cfc pour la faire casal l'ont jeté par
messieurs du show theme celui annoncé
moi monsieur je sais tout fait pour la
faire cassagne me suis cassé mais là je
vais chercher et mais voici déjà
monsieur maurice et oui en effet est il
mal à maurice est si je ne me trompe le
maladroit ou ça madame mori c'est ma
femme oui madame madame et bada
mais si j'avais vous expliquer cette
résistance du film le magistrat est muet
et l'homme du mans audi niort ces
professionnels voici monsieur cassagnas
monsieur le commissaire si je vous ai
prié de venir ici c'est que je tenais à
ce que la sphère s'instruisent y d'abord
mon bon ami lui chante l oit et j ai
souscrit d'autant mieux que j'ai été
sollicité par l'inculpé lui même qui se
défendra énergiquement de l'accusation
portée contre lui il m'a assuré que
possiblement ici nous connaîtrions le
véritable coupable
parfaitement dit parfaite alors dit bien
c'est ça
diderot ma chère amie c'est une affaire
personnelle monsieur k sign donc si tu
veux nous et c est pas du sang va
l'amener partout
je vous en prie madame non non non il ne
manque jamais le bas messieurs
est il nécessaire de vous rappeler les
faits à la requête de monsieur k 5 g
surprise cette nuit madame casting en
flagrant délit d'adultère et barres d'or
mais j'ai mes compliments je vous fais
mes compliments je suis le mari
parfaitement chargé de rattraper son
complice qui aurait pu le temps de
s'esquiver par la fenêtre et que nous
savions devoir être en caleçon opus
puisqu'il y avait oublié son pantalon
grand sa fuite
je lançais mes agents sur sa trace et
cinq minutes après c'est de me ramener à
l'individu dont la tenue précités et
qu'ils avaient arrêté dans l'appartement
voisin monsieur maurice est c'est une
coïncidence je suis victime d'une erreur
judiciaire
quoi alors si vous moi quoi de rien tu
m'avais dit qu'il était chemisier mais
vit dans la crainte de la taxation qui
nous donne des émotions quand vous le
voyez monsieur maurice et propose les
délégations les plus absolus aux
accusations formulées contre lui et de
fait si les apparences l'accablent je
dois dire que certaines circonstances
semblent donner raison à son dire nous
avons d'abord fait sur lui l'essai du
pantalon
il ne lui va pas du tout à ses preuves
en sa nous avons pris soin d'apporter
ici cette pièce à conviction et non mais
dans cette inutile on nous dit qu'on
croit quel besoin avez vous fait d'être
un complice vous avez surpris madame
sagnes en flagrant délit vous avez
trouvé un pantalon chez elle il me
semble que ça suffit vraiment ça me
suffit pas à la droite
il ne suffit pas qu'une femme peut à
présent en tête à tête avec un pantalon
pour que cela constitue en flagrant
délit tenez voici l'objet devant ma
femme et va le reconnaître
ça y est il s'agit maintenant de trouver
le propriétaire de ce vêtement ça nous
vient seulement comment le trouver voilà
mais pablo on ne trouvera pas mais que
voulez vous puissiez vous devez pas de
vous installer dans la rue et essayer ce
pantalon à tous les gens qui passeront
compte c'est une affaire à plat ces
fonds devaient fermer dès que nous ne la
font pas comme ça où on mange en
sortirait forme et en mode limonov salon
tiens mon pantalon sans pantalon vous
avez entendu son pantalon il a dit son
pantalon mais oui est ce qu'il y avait 1
500 enfants pour toi si c'est toujours
ton pantalon vous reconnaissez que ce
pantalon et vos robes plus que jamais
vous reconnaissez alors comme ctc tenu
40 rue datas tiens comment le savez-vous
il le reconnaît nous voyons messieurs il
le reconnaît ob oui pourquoi pas là
c'est clair brave garçon on va vous
appeler monsieur votre nom sont-ils
drôle dont 30 au rayon pourquoi et
pourtant vous demander si vous alliez
faire un 40e rues d'athènes
tiens par bleus j'ai laissé ma petite
femme à bord de petites femmes
on l'avait pas demandé vous doutez que
c'est aussi la mienne la vôtre c'est le
sachent le seul
pour qui je me cassais dans le placard
amazon donnera du sel je prenais after
monsieur le commissaire prégnante
le commissaire j'espère qu'enfin je le
tiens mon divorce son divorce à sakic
qui est voulons tous les deux non pas le
protecteur je suis même mari monsieur
c'est monsieur des voitures aux eaux
mais monsieur je ne savais pas qu'elle
était mariée elle n'avait rien dit non
je vous jure je vous jure que le mandat
myriade il suffit monsieur je sais ce
que je voulais savoir et je vais agir à
l'instant même madame messieurs je vous
salue un café alors monsieur monsieur s
le nom mais pas du tout monsieur j'y
comprends rien du tout j'ai un poids de
moi alors je vois que ma mission est
terminée
monsieur maurice est il ne me reste plus
qu à m'excuser auprès de madame je vous
présente mes respects monsieur
duchâtelet faut mais je vous à quoi par
ailleurs ici ce qu'on peut taper un
incident d'audience il croit que ce soit
en rien les idéaux
il a pu abuser de commission et par mois
en attendant puisque nous sommes seuls
profitez-en pour me rendre malade c'est
vrai qu'on fait tout et mon pantalon est
décidément c'est la journée des
pantalons aujourd'hui nous voyons frais
des mois à venir dans la poste avant le
verre au lion
mon mouchoir à mon porte-monnaie bête
mais la ligue a plus de lettres elle y
est plus grand sapin tête non c'est bien
mais ne revient pas à chercher écouter
voilà une jambe
voilà l'autre un bon alors moi j'en ai
deux qu'est ce que vous faites là mais
je pense que je m'entraîne je m'entraîne
au bois d'amont quant à madame du show
tél abbas est bien intéressante et bien
alors tu as vu pièce qui aurait pu se
douter ce farceur de grands avec madame
khassan lasser les contrôles et quand je
pense que tu as pu me soupçonner un
moment c'était ce gamin d'ailleurs ça ne
va pas autrement et ça il ya longtemps
que contre on avait fait part de ses
relations avec madame cassagne mois qui
viennent avec bon qu'il vous aurait de
l'argent et bien c'est moi qui payais
juillet pour deux mais ce qui me regarde
ce qu'il paraît qu'elle avait d'aussi
est vieux
qu'est ce qu'elle sait comment je voyais
pas son pari enfin c'est pas possible
qu'elle ait dit ça fait je suis pas un
vieux mois
attention qui m'attend c'est la mêlée
doublettes 3 a coupé mon esprit continue
oui bien que je suis au fait c est vous
qui étiez cette machinerie cassagne et
bien près tout oui là je crois que je ne
m'en sors pas pu tous ces mensonges
j'aime mieux avoue est carrément oui oui
j'étais cette nuit chez madame k sonne
enfin vous vous décidez je ne sais pas
menti il ne s'est pas nantis mettez
dedans si j'allais par blabla n'avait
pas trop rester vous monsieur tout est
fini entre game montredon gironde une
part de moi en janvier m mais voyons
voyons n'est pas dit quelque chose à
tenter une série dérivée three
allons voyons madame là tu vois
écoute ne veux je te jure que je ne
verrai plus madame khassan ni elle ni
d'eau wc ça c'était mettez pas dans ceux
ci tout ce qui s'est dit plus d'un
finalité plus de chasse plus de plus de
bourriches tient la briche rien ne
m'oblige à te dire eh bien la bourriche
elle venait de shell bash angie pied
parole tonnerre et même si tu ne me
crois pas j'ai la note
non en fait je les brûle et de chou
mais alors qu'est ce que c'est que ça
[Applaudissements]
c'est toi mais il est où mon ami je n'ai
qu'une parole
à l'heure qu'il est il n'y a plus
d'obstacle entre nous il n'y a plus
d'obstacle entre nous mais à propos de
commissions d'étude ansa
c'était un soir aux fins du mois
est ce que tu peux savoir libre de moi
même c'est à vous que je m'engage
pourquoi je sais c'est un jour ou deux
avant de fiançailles
dites vous bien que jeune agi de la
sorte que parce qu'il n'a bien voulu
mais parfaitement il s'était offert à
lady souffre et bien tu ne devrais pas
les routines je ne me rappelais plus du
tout cette lettre la tutelle a rappelé
l'homme est maman
maintenant je me rappelle très bien et
il tient à léontine en souvenir de ce
montant en souvenir du jour où tu m'a
écrit cette lettre par de nouveaux
jamais dans la vie il n'ya rien vous
entend messieurs les boîtes noires
comprend joindre à moi pour fait chier
attendant tous moi les autres lignes
puisque je te promets d'être à l'avenir
le modèle des épi alors pardonnez lui
c'est ça c'est un grand coupable mais
tais toi de toi
dans un mail aux attentes
permettez moi d'insister au nom de la
dame qui était cette nuit 40e rues de
nos valeurs c'est bon je pardonne ne
savait plus je chasserai peut-être mais
je ne laisserai plus
et moi à un as et ben moi je remporte
mon pantalon
mira mesdemoiselles messieurs la pièce
que nous avons eu le plaisir de jouer
pour vous ce soir est de georges feydeau
et les décors sont de rejet art
les costumes de donald cardwell
la mise en scène d'alain feydeau
avec bernard durand
edit albertini
hier mira
non robert là
ysl maillot
[Musique]
xavier vandenbergh
william sabatier
françoise fleury
yvonne godeau
et michel roux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]